parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
durable je t'écris ces quelques lignes
pour te dire que oui je suis prêt à
faire un petit bout de chemin avec toi
PS quand je parle de bout de chemin je
veux dire départ de chez moi arriver au
boulot puis retour maison si possible
tous les jours merci à toi le
covoiturage c'est convivial économique
et écologique avec le covoiturage
Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous propose
une nouvelle façon de vous déplacer les
inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.aglo-sqy.fr
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro d'équilibre le magazine
de l'environnement un numéro qui cette
fois va nous emmener au cœur des
énergies renouvelables l'hiver approche
c'est le moment de penser chauffage et
isolation malin et surtout respectueux
de l'environnement pour cela nous
partirons à la Maison de l'Environnement
découvrir un atelier pédagogique mais
aussi le plan régional de développement
éolien pour les ivelines mais avant cela
nous allons parler olation de l'habitat
avec vous Johann gerbau bonjour bonjour
nous sommes dans les locaux de l'Agence
Locale de l'énergie et du climat laalc
de Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous êtes
vous-même chargé du plan de la mission
énergie et climat pouvez-vous nous
expliquer en quoi consiste les missions
de l'ALEC alors les missions de l'Agence
Locale de l'énergie et du climat donc
Alec sont de renseigner les particulier
sur tout ce qui est maîtrise de
l'énergie et développement des énergies
renouvelables donc pour cela nous av n
avons ce que l'on appelle ici dans nos
locaux un espace infoénergie donc tout
particulier peut venir nous consulter
pour avoir des réponses sur l'isolation
sur son mode de chauffage sur la
construction d'une nouvelle maison ou
sur la rénovation d'un bâtiment dans
lequel il vivent ça c'est pour la
mission auprès des particuliers à côté
de cela nous accompagnons également les
collectivités territoriales alors quels
sont les matériaux que l'on peut
utiliser aujourd'hui pour améliorer son
isolation alors aujourd'hui en fait on
va trouver différents types
d'isolants qui vont être présents sur le
marché on a les isolants conventionnels
qu' l'on trouve sur le marché qui
représent à peu près 90 à 95 % de ce qui
est vendu en terme d'isolation donc les
laines de verre lainees de roche
polystyrène qui sont les matériaux
conventionnels qu'on va trouver donc le
le plus souvent et aujourd'hui on voit
de plus en plus de nouveaux matériaux
apparaître alors des matériaux qui sont
dit biosourcés ou naturels donc tel que
la laine de bois la laine de chanvre euh
la î de cellulose qui euh aujourd'hui
ourd'hui sont très intéressants parce
qu'ils ont une durée de vie assez longue
ils ont les mêmes performances
d'isolation que les matériaux que j'ai
cité précédemment tels que la laine de
verre et également ont également un
impact moindre sur sur l'environnement
voilà d'accord alors est-ce qu'il vaut
mieux isoler sa maison de l'intérieur ou
de l'extérieur alors de manière générale
c'est plutôt une isolation par
l'extérieur qu'on va préconiser parce
qu'une isolation qui va être réalisée
par l'extérieur va permettre de couper
également ce qu'on appelle les pont
thermiqu les ponts thermiques c'est les
défauts de liaison qu'on va avoir à
l'intérieur d'un bâtiment d'accord alors
est-ce que tous ces travaux qui peuvent
s'avérer onéreux euh son sont vraiment
utiles est-ce que ça vaut vraiment le
coup au final nous notre point de vue
c'est de dire que il faut d'abord
travailler sur l'enveloppe du bâtiment
sur l'isolation du bâtiment avant de
travailler sur le mode de chauffage tout
simplement parce que si on met un mode
de chauffage ultra performant mais que
le bâtiment est pas isolé il y a une
partie de ce qu'on va chauffer qui va
partir vers l'extérieur et donc leur
retour sur investissement d'un mode de
chauffage même performant se fera sur le
plus long terme par contre si on
travaille d'abord sur l'isolation du
bâtiment donc on calefeutre le bâtiment
donc on permet à la chaleur de rester à
l'intérieur du bâtiment et la plupart du
temps avec ce type de travaux là on a
des retours qui sont beaucoup plus
rapides en terme d'investissement est-ce
que les particuliers peuvent bénéficier
d'aide justement quand ils se lancent
dans ce type de travaux ah oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui il existe une aide
financière au niveau national qui est le
crédit d'impôt que les particul dont les
particuliers peuvent bénéficier ce
crédit d'impôt
euh correspond en fait à un pourcentage
qui va être appliqué en fonction des
travaux réalisés pour pouvoir bénéficier
du crédit d'impôt il faut que les
particuliers fassent les travaux sur
leur résidence principale et que ces
travaux soient réalisés par un
professionnel en fonction des travaux on
va avoir des taux qui vont être
différents qui vont aller de 15 % à 40 %
en fonction des des travaux mis en œuvre
d'accord bien écoutez merci beaucoup
pour toutes ces précisions ces
information il n'y a pas que les grands
qui sont concernés par les énergies
renouvelables les tout petits aussi la
Maison de l'Environnement organise
régulièrement des ateliers sur les
énergies renouvelables
regardez les défis du renouvelable ce
matin-là parents et enfants avaient
décidé de les relever à la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manil et amau petits
et grands étaient atablés autour des
trois atelier solaire éolien et
thermique ce matin on avait envie de
montrer ou de en tout cas d'apprendre
enfants de façon très simple quelles
sont les énergies renouvelables que l'on
peut utiliser pour bah essayer de
trouver d'autres solutions que le
pétrole ou les énergies fossiles nos
ingénieurs d'un jour ont pu bâtir leur
première maison en carton avec panneaux
photovoltaïques des véhicules
hydraulique ou à air comprimé et
participer à la course de voiture au
début ils viennent vraiment plus pour
jouer qu'autre chose mais très vite ils
comprennent que ça a une utilité et que
ça permet justement bah de remplacer des
énergies fossiles par des énergies
simples et des énergies naturelles qui
sont le soleil le vent et l'au l'eau le
vent n'ont désormais plus de secret pour
ces apprentis écolos les petits comme
les grands je trouais c'était un super
atelier pour les enfants aussi bien pour
les enfants que les adultes c'est
vraiment ils ont fait beaucoup de choses
une maison
regardez he tu peux décrire l'omé ce que
tu as fait un petit peu non ouais
qu'est-ce qui t'a plu exactement faire
la maison
ah réaliser une voiture et une voiture
avec qui marche avec de l'air avec un
moulin à
eau et la
voit en fait là faut souffler dans la
paille et après grâce au ballon ça ça
donne une impulsion après l' elle sort
et ça fait avancer la voiture prochaine
atelier le 15 décembre pour des
décorations de Noël à base de matériaux
de
récupération nous voici désormais face à
un cas bien concret d'un particulier qui
a conçu sa maison de manière entièrement
écologique cette maison c'est la vôtre
Thierry Gilbert bonjour et merci de nous
recevoir Bour tout plaisir pour moi
alors en quoi peut-on dire que cette
maison est écologique alors elle est
écologique principalement parce que déjà
elle est construite avec du bois 90 % de
bois donc le bois c'est c'est quelque
chose qui va stocker pendant toute sa
vie du du dioxyde de carbone du CO2
quand on le réutilise ensuite en
construction on utilise un stockage de
CO2 inerte donc donc rien que là déjà
c'est écologique ensuite il y a tout un
tas d'installations techniques dans la
maison qui font que elle est écologique
alors quels sont ces points techniques
justement alors les points techniques
les principaux c'est l'isolation parce
qu'elle est elle est elle est très très
bien isolé avec un matériau qui est de
la laine de bois encore du bois euh du
triple vitrage ensuite donc pour les
pour tout ce qui est fenêtre ensuite on
a au niveau du traitement du chauffage
on n pas de de chauffage traditionnel
électrique ou ou F ou G on a un
chauffage bois qui est ensuite retraité
dans la maison avec une VMC dou flux qui
va récupérer les calories dans le sol
via un pu canadien aérolique et et aussi
tout un tout un tas de de petits points
technique sur la récupération d'eau de
pluie la protection des contre les
champs électromagnétiques et ainsi de
suite ENF plein de choses qui font que à
la fin dans la finalité on arrive à
avoir une maison bien conçue et surtout
très écologique alors justement
qu'est-ce qui vous a motivé vous Orient
dans dans dans cette aventure alors à
l'origine on voulait construire une
maison alors peut-être faire construire
on savait pas encore et puis on a trouvé
on a eu l'opportunité de trouver c ben
ce terrain là et puis on s'est dit tant
qu'à construire essayer de construire
une maison qui soit le qui qui respecte
le plus possible son environnement qui
qui nous permettent à nous de faire
aussi des économies parce que c'est
aussi c'est aussi le but rechercher et
puis au fur et à mesure au début on
prend une petite feuille on fait des
plans ensuite on commence à acheter un
logiciel puis on prend goû et puis vu
que j'avais quelques compétences dans
dans certains domaines à défaut d'avoir
de réelles compétences professionnelles
j'ai je me suis dit bah pourquoi pas la
construire moi-même alors au final ça
fait 3 ans que votre maison est
désormais terminée quel bilan tirez-vous
ça valait vraiment la peine moi j'ai
toujours vécu en appartement avant de
vivre ici c'est c'est exceptionnel moi
enfin en tout cas c'est ce que nous on
ressent au niveau de du chauffage au
niveau de l'ambiance thermique et
ambiance acoustique et puis au niveau
économique oui bien sûr parce que
aujourd'hui tout frais confondu je paye
d'électricité je paye 54 € par mois et
en eau je dépasse pas les 6 € mensuel et
c'est tout ce que je paye en facture en
facture d'énergie pour un confort
optimum au quotidien oui pour un confort
optimum le chauffage lu est obtenu via
mon foyer et je mets C steres de bois à
l'année dedans donc c'est c'est très
très peu pour pour les gens qui qui qui
qui se chauffe un peu au bois C Ster à
l'année pour une maison de 125 m² c'est
que d d'accord et bien merci beaucoup
beaucoup pour tous ces conseils et puis
pour cette visite ça c'est moi c'est moi
que ça fait plaisir merci au total la
maison écologique de Thierry Gilbert lui
aura coûté 150000 € alors pour ou contre
les énergies renouvelables en tout cas
ces derniers temps certaines font parler
d'elles ce sont les éoliennes un plan
régional de développement vient d'être
présenté dans les Yvelines 109 communes
sont concernées par ces implantations
regardez les ivelinois doivent se
préparer les éoliennes vont pousser à
côté de leur maison d'ici à 2020 la
consultation du SRE francilien le schéma
régional éolien pour l'Île-de-France
vient de se terminer ce plan définit les
zones favorables au développement de
l'énergie éolienne en clair le SRE est
une sorte de nomenclature pour les
collectivités locales ce seront aux élus
locaux de mettre en place des projets de
construction de parc éoliens sur ces
zones le schéma éolien ne définit pas
des projets éoliens mais définit à
l'échelle régional de territoires sur
lesquels pourront être portés des
projets la nuance est subtile mais elle
est d'importance puisque les projets
aoliens très concrètement seront portés
à l'initiative des maires des
différentes communes du territoire situé
en zone favorbl ou des présidents
d'intercommunalité situés dans les zones
favorables du schéma régional éolien sur
l'île-de-fance 671 villes sont
concernées dont 109 communes dans les
Yvelines cette carte montre que dans le
département trois zones ont été
sélectionnées pour l'implantation
d'éoliennes au sud du département sur la
plaine d'aabi à l'ouest près d'Oudan et
au sud de mantelajolie l'association
Eveline environnement Redoute pour une
facture salée pour le consommateur
aucune inquiétude à avoir pour le
conseil régional la deuxème énergie
renouvelable celle qui arrive tout de
suite après l'hydraulique c'est
l'énergie éolienne pour un prix compris
entre 69 et 80 € du mgawh donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui sur une énergie renouvelable
qui est compétitive par rapport à des
énergies conventionnelles voire même qui
sont enfin voir même une énergie qui est
située en dessous du coû de production
des énergies fossiles ou des énergies
fissiles classiques mais l'association
Eveline environnement s'inquiète aussi
du danger sur la faune et le paysage le
plan assure qu'aucune éolienne ne serait
implanté par exemple à moins de 500 m
d'habitation à l'heure actuelle il faut
aller à guitrancour pour trouver la
seule éolienne du département d'ici à
2020 100 à 180 éoliennes devraient être
installé dans la
région ainsi s'achève ce nouveau numéro
d'équilibre merci de l'avoir suivi avant
de nous quitter voici quelques dates
écolo à noter dans vos agendas le 27
novembre la Maison de l'Environnement
propose la projection d'un film sur la
présence des OGM et du nucléaire dans
notre environnement sans test
approfondis alors tout ce cobail ce sera
la question posée par ce documentaire et
puis sachez que tout au long de l'année
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat que nous avons vu dans ce numéro
accueil et conseil sur toutes les
questions liées à l'isolation de
l'habitat nous on se retrouve le 14
décembre pour un numéro d'équilibre
spécial fait de fin d'année
Ciao